.
>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN LAUNCHED HIS
2024 CPAIGN THIS WEEK.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS HAD
A VERY PROMINENT ROLE.
OF COURSE, HE WANTS TO REMIND US
OF THE HISTORIC, DIVERSE CHOICE
THAT HE MADE, BUT HE ALSO MAY BE
HOPING TO CALM THE WORRY VOICED
BY MANY AMERICANS ABOUT HIS AGE.
IN A RECENT NBC NEWS POLL, 70%
OF ADULTS SAID BIDEN SHOULD NOT
RUN AGAIN.
ASKED IF AGE WAS A FACTOR, A
TOTAL OF 69% SAID YES.
YOU'LL REMEMBER IN 1984, CONCERN
WAS VOICED ABOUT RONALD REAGAN
RUNNING FOR REELECTION AT AGE
73.
AT 80, BIDEN IS ALREADY THE
OLDEST PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
IF REELECTED, HE'D BE SWORN IN
AT AGE 82.
AT THE END OF A SECOND TERM,
HE'D BE 86.
THAT MEANS INCREASED FOCUS ON
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS.
RIGHT NOW, HER AGGREGATE
DISAPPROVAL RATING IS CURRENTLY
AT 54%.
SHE RECENTLY HAS BEEN MAKING
APPEARANCES AROUND OTHER POPULAR
DEMOCRATIC CAUSES SUCH AS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ABORTION
RIGHTS.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF RON KLAIN SAID THIS.
>> WHY HASN'T SHE BEEN ABLE TO
SHAKE THE PERCEPTION THAT SHE'S
BAD AT HER JOB?
I KNOW SEXISM AND RACISM ARE A
HUGE PROBLEM, BUT THAT DOESN'T
EXPLAIN ALL OF THE BAD PRESS.
>> SEXISM AND RACISM ARE PART OF
THE PROBLEM, NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
I THINK SHE WAS NOT AS WELL
KNOWN IN NATIONAL POLITICS
BEFORE SHE BECAME VICE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK SHE JUST HASN'T GOTTEN
THE CREDIT FOR ALL SHE'S DONE.
HOPEFULLY DURING THE CAMPAIGN
SEASON, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET
MORE OF A CHANCE TO SEE HER ON
THE STUMP AND GET TO KNOW HER A
LITTLE BETTER.
>> MY NEXT GUEST RECENTLY WROTE
THIS COLUMN IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," WHY KAMALA HARRIS
MATTERS SO MUCH IN 2024.
THOMAS FRIEDMAN JOINS ME NOW.
HE IS A THREE-TIME PULITZER
PRIZE WINNING "NEW YORK TIMES"
COLUMNIST AND THE AUTHOR OF
SEVEN BEST SELLING BOOKS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK.
YOU ARE VERY MUCH FOR THE
REELECTION OF JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S WHAT PROMPTED YOU TO
WRITE THIS PIECE IN PART.
>> YES.
THE REAL POINT OF MY PIECE WAS
THAT THERE ARE, IN MY VIEW,
WE'RE AT A CRITICAL JUNCTURE AND
THREE THINGS CANNOT HAPPEN.
ISRAEL CANNOT TURN INTO HUNGARY
AND AUTHORITARIAN DEMOCRACY.
PUTIN CANNOT WIN IN UKRAINE.
AND DONALD TRUMP MUST NEVER,
EVER, EVER, EVER, EVER BE BACK
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
SO THAT IS MY PRIORITY.
THAT IS MY FOCUS.
I'M ASKING WHAT IS THE BEST
DEMOCRATIC TICKET TO WIN THAT
ELECTION?
TO ME, YOU NEED A TICKET THAT
APPEALS TO THE VERY FORCES THAT
ENABLED DEMOCRATS TO DO SO WELL
IN THE MIDTERMS, WHICH WERE
MODERATES, INDEPENDENTS WHO
LOOKED AT TRUMP, HIS AGENDA AND
PARTICULARLY THE ELECTION
DENIALISM AND VOTED AGAINST
VIRTUALLY EVERY ELECTION DENIER.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A CLOSE
ELECTION IF IT'S TRUMP VERSUS
BIDEN.
WE NEED THE CENTER.
WE NEED THE MODERATE AND
INDEPENDENTS AND WHITE WORKING
CLASS TO COME OUT FOR BIDEN IN
ENOUGH NUMBERS THAT HE CAN WIN.
THIS IS CODE RED.
>> HERE'S A PARAGRAPH IN THE
PIECE THAT I CIRCLED.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS HAS NOT
ELEVATED HER STATURE IN THE LAST
TWO, PLUS YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM
WAS, WHETHER SHE'S IN OVER HER
HEAD OR IS CONTENDING WITH A MIX
OF SEXISM AND RACISM.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT DOUBTS AMONG
VOTERS ABOUT HER ABILITY TO
SERVE AS PRESIDENT, WHICH WERE
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH FOR HER TO
QUIT AS A PRESIDENTIAL HAVE NOT
GONE AWAY.
RON KLAIN'S OPINION SEEMED TO BE
BUYING THE IDEA THAT IT'S SEXISM
AND RACISM.
YOU DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A CHOICE
AMONG THESE CAUSES OF WHAT IT
WOULD BE.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT.
FOR SOME VOTERS, SHE COMES OFF
AS INAUTHENTIC AND SHE HASN'T
BEEN ABLE TO OVERCOME THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM
IS.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
A PRESIDENT THAT'S GOING TO BE
86 YEARS OLD AT THE END OF HIS
SECOND TERM, THE QUESTION
BECOMES MUCH MORE IMPORTANT.
IF TRUMP IS THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE AND SAY HE ASKS NIKKI
HALEY OR TIM SCOTT TO RUN WITH
HIM.
THAT COULD CAUSE A LOT OF VOTES
TO LOOK AT THAT TICKET AND PLUG
THEIR NOSE AND VOTE FOR HIM
AGAIN.
THAT'S MY WHOLE FOCUS.
I HAVE NOTHING ABOUT THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
I WISH HER WELL.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
MOMENT.
WE NEED PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT
TRUMP MUST NEVER BE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AGAIN.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO HAVE THE
BEST TICKET POSSIBLE AND ONE
THAT WILL DEFINITELY APPEAL TO
MODERATES AND INDEPENDENTS WHO
SHOWED UP FOR BIDEN IN ENOUGH
NUMBERS TO REALLY TIP THE
MIDTERM THE RIGHT WAY.
>> IN THE PIECE YOU ARGUE THAT
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO DEAL WITH
THIS HEAD ON.
HE NEEDS TO ADDRESS IT.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT DOES
THAT ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE?
>> WELL, SOME PEOPLE TELL YOU
MAYBE HE SHOULD CONSIDER A
DIFFERENT VICE PRESIDENT,
SOMEONE LIKE HAKEEM JEFFRIES,
WHO PLAYS VERY WELL TO THE
CENTER.
BIDEN CLEARLY DOES NOT WANT THE
GO DOWN THAT ROAD.
YOU AIRED HIS ANNOUNCEMENT
VIDEO.
MAYBE THERE'S WAYS TO HELP VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS ESTABLISH
HERSELF MORE WITH CENTRISTS AND
INDEPENDENTS.
JUST THE ABORTION ISSUE WILL
BRING ENOUGH VOTERS AROUND AND
THERE ISN'T A QUESTION OF
SUCCESSION, I THINK IS A
DANGEROUS, RECKLESS WAY TO GO
INTO THIS NEXT ELECTION.
>> TOM, I LOOKED AT THE READER
PICKS AMONG THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
READER RESPONSES.
THERE'S A CONSISTENT THEME TO A
NUMBER OF THEM WHICH IS TO SAY
THAT THE OUT HERE IS THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> FOR THAT, YOU WOULD NEED A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE TO RETIRE.
>> TRUE.
>> IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN, I
THINK THAT'S A VERY LEGITIMATE
POSSIBILITY.
>> I THINK THERE'S SOME
POLITICAL MALPRACTICE BEING
COMMITTED ON THE PART OF THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT RELATES TO
THIS.
NO DOUBT YOU SAW THE STORY ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT AT THE PRESSER
WITH THE KOREAN PRESIDENT
REACHING INTO HIS POCKET,
PULLING OUT A QUESTION, CALLING
ON A REPORTER FROM THE L.A.
TIMES.
I NEED TO MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT
THERE WAS NOT AN APPLES TO
APPLES OF WHAT WAS IN HIS POCKET
AND WHAT SHE THEN ASKED OF HIM.
NEVERTHELESS, IT FOSTERS THIS
PERCEPTION THAT HE REQUIRES THAT
LEVEL OF ASSISTANCE.
>> I'M ONE OF THE FEW REPORTERS
WHO HAS HAD A CHANCE TO HAVE
LUNCH WITH THE PRESIDENT BY
OURSELVES, THE TWO OF US.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH HIS
COGNITIVE ABILITY, HIS AWARENESS
ON ISSUES.
HE CAN GO DEEP.
WE WERE TALKING MOSTLY ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT NOW,
BUT I AM CONCERNS THAT SIX YEARS
FROM NOW THAT COULD BE AN ISSUE.
THEREFORE, MY POINT IS THE VICE
PRESIDENTIAL CHOICE IN THIS
ELECTION WILL MATTER MORE THAN
EVER.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO HAVE THE RIGHT
VICE PRESIDENT GOING INTO THIS
ELECTION.
THIS ELECTION WILL MATTER MORE
THAN EVER.
FOUR MORE YEARS OF TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, PUTIN IN UKRAINE OR
ISRAEL GOING AUTOCRATIC AND THE
WHOLE WORLD AS YOU KNOW IT WILL
BE CHANGED IN A VERY BAD WAY.
DONALD TRUMP MUST NEVER, EVER,
EVER, EVER, EVER BE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AGAIN.
>> FINALLY THOUGHT.
QUICKLY, THIS IS A SENSITIVE
SUBJECT.
I'VE TRIED TO HANDLE IT IN AN
ADULT FASHION IN THE SAME WAY
YOU'VE WRITTEN ABOUT IT.
WHAT KIND OF REACTION DID YOU
GET PERSONALLY TO ADDRESSING
THIS MATTER?
>> READ THE COMMENTS ON THE
COLUMN.
THEY WERE OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE POINT I WAS
RAISING.
>> THEY WERE.
IT'S TRUE.
STICK AROUND.
I WANT TO LEAN ON A THREE-TIME
PULITZER PRIZE WINNER TO RESPOND
TO SOCIAL MEDIA.
I WANT TO READ IT ALOUD.
IF ANYONE WANTS TO WATCH KAMALA
HARRIS QUESTION A WITNESS IN A
SENATE HEARING, YOU WOULD SEE
WHY I THINK SHE IS TALENTED.
SORRY SOME HAVE A BIASSED
IMPRESSION OF HER.
SHE MAY NOT BE POPULAR, BUT SO
WHAT?
YOU WOULD SAY WHAT TO ROBERT ON
THAT, TOM?
>> THE POLLS ARE THE POLLS.